earliest child to survive a pregnancy is
21 weeks so you're aborting children
that hypothetically could survive on
their own outside the womb I think that
child that was going to be born the life
that is going to live do you think it's
going to live for a good life and then
isn't that isn't that actually being
cruel to this child that would be born
my question is do you believe that poor
children are less valuable they're not
less valuable they're just not going to
have a good value of life so why should
that why should they why should I put a
child on this Earth that's gonna not not
have a good quality when I could do it
give it a good quality of life when I'm
prepared in the future quality of life I
have two things one the majority of
abortions are with women that make over
forty seven thousand dollars per year so
it's not an income thing only only eight
percent of women anything do they I
don't I don't when you're firing back at
these facts I don't they don't mean
anything
because to me I don't think you should
be having sex if you can't afford a
child